Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The King left at noon. The heads of the two bodyguards led the procession on pikes. Following them were 40 to 50 members of the bodyguard on foot and unarmed, escorted by a body of men armed with sabres and pikes. After that came two of the bodyguard wearing high boots with neck wounds, blood-stained shirts and torn garments. Each was held by two men in the national uniform with
感谢收听《历史余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。国王于中午离开。两名保镖的头颅被插在长矛上，走在队伍最前面。紧随其后的是 40 到 50 名徒手步行、由持军刀和长矛的人员押送的保镖。再后面是两名保镖，他们穿着高筒靴，颈部有伤，衬衫沾满血迹，衣衫褴褛。每人由两名身穿国民制服的人押着，
drawn swords in their hands. Further back, one could see a group of the bodyguard mounted on horses, some riding pillion and others in the saddle with a member of the national guard riding behind them. They were surrounded by men and women who compelled them to shout Vive la Nation! and to eat and drink with them. A mixed bag of pikemen, Swiss guards, soldiers of the Flanders Regiment, women plastered with cockades and carrying poplar branches, and other women sitting astride on the guns, came before and after the king's coach. Every musket was wreathed in oak leaves in token of the victory, and there was a continual
手中拿着出鞘的剑。再往后，可以看到一群骑马的保镖，有的两人共乘一骑，有的独自骑马，身后坐着一名国民卫队队员。他们被男男女女包围着，这些人强迫他们高喊“法兰西万岁！”并与他们一起吃喝。国王马车的前后，簇拥着一群形形色色的人：持长矛者、瑞士卫队、佛兰德斯团的士兵、身上贴满帽章并手持杨树枝的妇女，以及骑在炮架上的其他妇女。每一支火枪都缠绕着橡树叶，以象征胜利，并且不断地
discharge of musketry as the people cried, We are bringing the baker, Mrs. Baker and the baker's boy, slogans of gross insult to the queen and threats against priests and the nobles. Such was the procession, barbarous and criminal, that surrounded the king, the queen and the royal family on the six-hour drive to the Hôtel de Ville. So that was the Marquis de Ferrières, Charles-Élie de Ferrières, no less, who we met a couple of episodes ago. He was a diplomat, an aristocrat, and a delegate to the Estates General. And this is his account, Tom, of the October days, a truly shocking moment in French monarchical history, certainly a very traumatic moment for Louis XVI and Marie Antoinette. It's the moment when they are effectively dragged by a mob from the Palace of Versailles.
鸣枪，人们高喊着：“我们带来了面包师、面包师夫人和面包师学徒”，这些口号是对王后的粗俗侮辱，也是对神职人员和贵族的威胁。这就是在长达六小时前往市政厅的车程中，包围着国王、王后和王室成员的野蛮而罪恶的游行队伍。所以，这就是我们几集前见过的费里埃侯爵，查尔斯-埃利·德·费里埃。他是一位外交官、贵族，也是三级会议的代表。汤姆，这就是他关于十月事件的叙述，这是法国君主制历史上一个真正令人震惊的时刻，对路易十六和玛丽·安托瓦内特来说，这无疑是一个非常痛苦的时刻。这是他们实际上被暴民从凡尔赛宫拖走的时刻。
Well, Dominic, a mob, or depending on your perspective, revolutionaries burning with a zeal for liberty. Yeah, it sounds like it, doesn't it? All the neck wounds, the people eating and drinking, shouting. But he's an aristocrat. I mean, obviously, this is the whole point. Perspectives on this differ quite radically. They do differ.
嗯，多米尼克，暴民，或者根据你的视角，是燃烧着自由热情的革命者。是的，听起来确实如此，不是吗？所有的颈部伤口，人们吃喝、叫喊。但他是一位贵族。我的意思是，显然，这正是重点所在。对此的看法确实有很大的不同。确实不同。
And so we're joined by Rob Spier himself, Tom Holland. So, Tom, this is one of the great set piece moments, not just in French history, but in all European history, isn't it? The humiliation of the king and queen by this group, either as you would say, of tenderhearted representatives of the people or slavering beasts from the slums and sewers,
所以我们请来了罗伯·斯皮尔本人，汤姆·霍兰。那么，汤姆，这是法国历史上，乃至整个欧洲历史上最伟大的标志性时刻之一，不是吗？国王和王后被这群人羞辱，无论你是称他们为“心地善良的人民代表”，还是“来自贫民窟和下水道的贪婪野兽”，
depending of course on the way you frame it. So the baker, Mrs. Baker and the baker's boy, they're the king, the queen, and the dauphin. Who's what, five? Something like that? Yeah, something like that. So they effectively, from this point onwards, they are prisoners of the revolution held in captivity. Yes. You could argue this is the great turning point in the story of the revolution? I think certainly for the king and queen, it's a much more significant turning point than the storming of the Bastille. And it's clearly a massive turning point in the history of the revolution. But you could equally argue that it is drawing a line under a whole series of measures and developments that have been happening over the previous months. It's a kind of logical conclusion to what's been happening. So just to remind listeners of what those developments are,
当然，这取决于你如何定义它。所以面包师、面包师夫人和面包师学徒，他们就是国王、王后和王储。王储几岁？五岁左右？差不多吧。是的，差不多。所以从这一刻起，他们实际上成为了革命的囚徒，被关押起来。是的。你可以说这是革命故事中的伟大转折点吗？我认为对国王和王后来说，这肯定比攻占巴士底狱更具重大意义。这显然是革命史上一个巨大的转折点。但你同样可以说，这是在过去几个月里发生的一系列措施和发展的基础上画上了一个句号。这是正在发生的事情的一种逻辑结论。为了提醒听众这些发展是什么，
the Bastille stormed on the 14th of July. And then that August of 1789, you have the revocation of feudal privileges where all the aristocrats and abbots and people stand up and renounce all their various perks. And that's passed on the 11th of August. And then on the 26th of August, approval is given in the National Assembly for the Declaration of the Rights of Man and the Citizen, which is what we were talking about in yesterday's episode. But what we kind of briefly touched on, but didn't really explore, is the way that the Declaration of the Rights of Man, just on the ideological level, it raises as many questions as it answers. And there are definitely those in the National Assembly, but also more broadly in Paris, who feel it does not go far enough. So what we didn't talk
7月14日攻占了巴士底狱。然后是1789年8月，废除了封建特权，所有的贵族、修道院长和人们站起来放弃了他们各自的各种津贴。这是在8月11日通过的。然后是8月26日，国民议会批准了《人权和公民权宣言》，这就是我们在昨天的节目中讨论的内容。但我们简要提到但没有真正探讨的是，《人权宣言》在意识形态层面上提出的问题和它解决的问题一样多。在国民议会中，以及在巴黎更广泛的范围内，肯定有人觉得它走得还不够远。所以我们昨天没有谈到的是，
about yesterday, which I'm sure lots of our particularly female listeners will have been wondering, is what about the rights of women and the citizeness? And that is a topic that we'll be looking at later. Essentially, there is quite, I think, a misogynist tone to revolutionary zeal. Well, all the stuff about virtue and virility has been laying the ground for that, right? They always talk about the oath of the Horatii, great Romans, but they're always talking about men, never about women. Yes. And although women do play a key part in this story, they tend to be a kind of anonymous mass. That is how they're celebrated, not as individuals. Also, the other kind of burning question, then as now, what about slaves? The French own huge
我相信我们很多女性听众肯定会好奇，女性和女公民的权利呢？这是一个我们稍后会探讨的话题。本质上，我认为革命热情中有一种相当厌女的基调。嗯，所有关于美德和阳刚之气的言论都为此奠定了基础，对吧？他们总是谈论霍拉蒂兄弟的誓言，伟大的罗马人，但他们谈论的总是男人，从不谈论女人。是的。虽然女性在这个故事中扮演了关键角色，但她们往往是一种匿名的大众。这就是她们被赞美的方式，而不是作为个体。此外，当时和现在一样，另一个紧迫的问题是，奴隶怎么办？法国在加勒比海拥有巨大的
plantations in the Caribbean. They say liberty for all, but equally they say property rights must be respected. So there is an unresolved tension there, again, that we might explore in due course. But of course, more immediately for the future of France and its constitution, what about the monarchy? Because how is the role of the king to be squared with the declaration and with the ideals of the revolution? So yesterday we were looking at the church, but in a way, the king is an even bigger roadblock to that idea of a single nation, a single patrie. Because as we were saying before, a lot of these revolutionaries are inspired by Montesquieu's ideas about a mixed constitution, a separation of powers, and the idea of the British constitutional monarchy as a model.
种植园。他们说人人享有自由，但同样他们也说必须尊重财产权。所以那里存在一种未解决的紧张关系，我们可能会在适当的时候探讨。但当然，对于法国及其宪法的未来而言，更直接的问题是，君主制怎么办？因为国王的角色如何与宣言和革命的理想相协调？所以昨天我们关注的是教会，但在某种程度上，国王是实现单一国家、单一祖国这一理念的更大障碍。因为正如我们之前所说，许多革命者受到孟德斯鸠关于混合宪法、权力分立以及以英国君主立宪制为模型的思想的启发。
So somebody like the Comte de Mirabeau, who we've talked about, a great sort of figure in the assembly at this point. He's all about a British style monarchy, isn't he? And they need somebody to play that part. What they're not talking about at this point is a Republican democracy. They have a king shaped hole and they want a patriot king to fill it. They do. So Mirabeau is the hero of the revolution. He's seen as a great patriot, but he is allying himself with kind of nobles who are less motivated by revolutionary fervor. I mean, they are literally a metropolitan elite. These are nobles from Paris who are very rich, very highly educated, and who are fascinated by the British example. So, Anglomanie, the fascination with England as a model model has been a trend running throughout the 18th century,
所以像米拉波伯爵这样的人，我们谈到过，他是当时议会中的一个伟大人物。他完全支持英式君主制，不是吗？他们需要有人来扮演这个角色。他们此时谈论的不是共和民主。他们有一个国王形状的空缺，他们想要一位爱国国王来填补它。他们确实想要。所以米拉波是革命的英雄。他被视为一位伟大的爱国者，但他正在与那些不太受革命热情驱动的贵族结盟。我的意思是，他们实际上是大都市精英。这些是来自巴黎的贵族，他们非常富有，受过高等教育，并且对英国的例子非常着迷。所以，“英国狂热”（Anglomanie），即对英国作为模型的迷恋，一直是贯穿18世纪的一种趋势，
even as France has been at war with Britain. And so Mirabeau and these kind of metropolitan nobles are proposing in the National Assemblies, they've got a kind of constitutional committee set up to ponder these issues. They're saying that we should model our constitution on British practice, although they are very, very careful to point out that their version will be better than the British one because they will learn from the British example. No such version exists, even in theory. You might think that. So what they are proposing is an elected National Assembly, which would correspond to the House of Commons, a Senate, which would be drawn from the great
即使法国一直与英国处于战争状态。因此，米拉波和这些大都市贵族在国民议会中提出建议，他们设立了一个宪法委员会来思考这些问题。他们说我们应该以英国的做法为蓝本制定我们的宪法，尽管他们非常非常小心地指出，他们的版本会比英国的好，因为他们会从英国的例子中吸取教训。即使在理论上，也不存在这样的版本。你可能会这么想。所以他们提议的是一个民选的国民议会，这相当于下议院，一个参议院，将从伟大的
and the good and obviously corresponds to the House of Lords. And this Senate, initially, they wanted to be for life. And then there are kind of objections to this. And so they say, well, it could be for six years. So drawing on the American exemplar. And they, as you say, they want the king to play the part that the British king plays. And essentially the British king, with the glorious revolution hanging over his or her head, the sense that a king who doesn't play his part can be kicked out. The British king has the power of veto over all legislation, but essentially is very, very reticent in using it. And I think that is what they want. They want someone who will have the power of veto because that will kind of provide a check on what they would see as excesses of popular fervour. But at the same time, they need a king who will not be
和优秀的人中选出，显然对应于上议院。而且这个参议院，最初他们希望是终身的。然后对此有一些反对意见。所以他们说，好吧，可以是六年。借鉴美国的例子。而且，正如你所说，他们希望国王扮演英国国王扮演的角色。本质上，英国国王，在光荣革命的阴影下，有一种感觉，即不履行职责的国王可以被赶下台。英国国王对所有立法都有否决权，但本质上在使用时非常非常克制。我认为这就是他们想要的。他们想要一个拥有否决权的人，因为这可以对他们所认为的民众狂热的过度行为起到制约作用。但与此同时，他们需要一个不会
too ready to use it. And the question is, is Louis XVI qualified to play that role? So that's one issue. But the other issue facing the monarciens, as they come to be called, the monarchists, is the fact that there are lots of radical deputies in the assembly who view any prospect of the king having any kind of veto as an absolute outrage. Yeah. One difference between the, as it were, the British revolution, if you want to call it that, which nobody ever does, and the French revolution is in Britain, the idea of the separation of powers, as in the United States, is seen as incredibly healthy and organic and a necessary check and a balance. But in France, you now have this sort of romantic
太急于使用它的人。问题是，路易十六有资格扮演这个角色吗？所以这是一个问题。但君主立宪派（monarchiens）面临的另一个问题是，议会中有许多激进的代表，他们认为国王拥有任何形式的否决权的前景都是绝对的暴行。是的。如果把英国革命称为革命（没人这么叫），那么它与法国革命的一个区别在于，在英国，权力分立的思想，就像在美国一样，被视为极其健康、有机且必要的制衡。但在法国，你现在有这种浪漫的
fervour and the idea of la nation and the assembly reflecting the general will of the nation. So there are lots of people who say, well, why would we divide it up? We've just done away with different orders. Yeah. So the three estates have all been swallowed up into the National Assembly because essentially, if you're having a Senate of the great and the good that means bishops it means aristocrats so you can understand the suspicion so the abbé d'issier who we met early on in the debate around the three estates versailles he describes the whole proposal as a launched against the national will against the entire nation so comparing it to a kind of unjust monarchical repression of liberty. And that idea of the national will, quite a dangerous idea, you might say, in the long run. But also the idea that sovereignty resides in the nation, which is one of the key principles
热情，以及“民族”（la nation）和反映民族普遍意志的议会的理念。所以有很多人说，好吧，我们为什么要把它分开？我们刚刚废除了不同的等级。是的。所以三个等级都被国民议会吞并了，因为本质上，如果你要建立一个由伟大和优秀人物组成的参议院，那就意味着主教，意味着贵族，所以你可以理解这种怀疑。所以西哀士神父，我们在关于凡尔赛三级会议的辩论中早些时候见过他，他将整个提议描述为针对民族意志、针对整个民族的攻击。所以将其比作一种不公正的君主制对自由的压制。而那种民族意志的理念，从长远来看，可以说是一个相当危险的理念。但主权属于民族的理念，也是《人权宣言》的关键原则之一，
of the Declaration of Rights. And if that is the case, then how can any individual even the king stand against the sovereignty of the nation and it's a real problem and it results in the national assembly essentially kind of splitting into rival factions and what happens is the monachia the the enthusiasts for the kind of british style constitution start to congregate on the right side of the meeting hall and their opponents those who want a more radical solution on the left and dominic that's a division that we still see stamped on politics to this very day yeah left and right but actually they reach a kind of compromise don't they so this is what september 1789 they reject a second chamber. That's decisively rejected. And the Constitutional Committee, which is full of all these kind of metropolitan elite types, that gets dissolved. So that's clearly a victory for the more radical wing.
如果情况确实如此，那么任何个人，即使是国王，怎么能对抗民族的主权呢？这是一个真正的问题，它导致国民议会本质上分裂成敌对的派系。发生的情况是，君主立宪派，那些英式宪法的狂热者，开始聚集在会议厅的右侧，而他们的对手，那些想要更激进解决方案的人，则聚集在左侧。多米尼克，这种划分至今仍印在政治上。是的，左派和右派。但实际上他们达成了一种妥协，不是吗？所以这是1789年9月，他们拒绝了第二个议院。这被果断地拒绝了。而那个充满了所有这些大都市精英类型的宪法委员会被解散了。所以这显然是更激进派别的胜利。
But you're right, around the veto, there is a kind of compromise that doesn't really satisfy anyone. So the king is allowed a veto, but it's a suspensive one. So it's a bit like the House of Lords in, was it 1910 or something? And Asquith, it's great to get Asquith back on the show and Asquith's Britain. So yeah, the House of Lords can postpone legislation or sort of block it, but then basically the commons can break the logjam under the Parliament Act. So the king can veto legislation three times. And then basically if they bring it back again. Which I think effectively means two years. Right.
但你是对的，关于否决权，有一种并没有真正满足任何人的妥协。所以国王被允许拥有否决权，但它是中止性的。所以这有点像上议院在1910年左右的情况？阿斯奎斯，很高兴阿斯奎斯回到节目中，还有阿斯奎斯的英国。所以是的，上议院可以推迟立法或阻止它，但基本上下议院可以根据《议会法案》打破僵局。所以国王可以否决立法三次。然后基本上如果他们再次提出。我认为这实际上意味着两年。对。
So he has a two year block on legislation. And then if they come back and say, no, we still want it. He then can't resist it. Which actually to me seems quite a good, you know, it's a safety valve. It's a cooling off period. But the right wing don't like it because it makes it impossible to preserve a kind of genuine balance of powers. Yeah. That's very important to them and it doesn't satisfy the radicals because the king can still frustrate the will of the sovereign people yeah so both sides
所以他对立法有两年的阻碍期。然后如果他们回来并说，不，我们仍然想要它。他就不能再抵制了。这对我来说实际上看起来是一个相当好的安全阀，一个冷静期。但右翼不喜欢它，因为它使得保持一种真正的权力平衡变得不可能。是的。这对他们来说非常重要，而且它不能满足激进派，因为国王仍然可以挫败主权人民的意志。是的，所以双方
are kind of cross but there's also i think by this point a sense that what people in the national assembly think is not necessarily decisive because there is also the will of the people as expressed by the inhabitants of Paris. And in Paris, people don't understand the veto at all. They kind of think it's a new tax, lots of them. And even those who don't, they don't really know what it is, but they're against it. That's the bottom line. And this is driven, I think, by, first of all, a kind of growing sense of hostility to the king personally. And this is fostered by the fact that he has been notably silent about the repudiation of feudalism and the declaration of rights yeah and then on the 19th of september he does finally comment on this kind of repudiation
都有点不高兴。但我认为到这个时候，人们感觉到国民议会中人们的想法并不一定是决定性的，因为还有巴黎居民所表达的人民意志。在巴黎，人们根本不理解否决权。他们中的很多人认为这是一种新税。即使是那些不这么认为的人，他们也不真正知道它是什么，但他们反对它。这就是底线。我认为这是由首先对国王个人的日益增长的敌意所驱动的。而这一点被他明显对废除封建制度和人权宣言保持沉默的事实所助长。是的，然后在9月19日，他终于对这种废除
of feudal rights but he hedges it around with so many qualifications that it ends up sounding like he's actually rejecting it the deputies are very upset about this. And in Paris, everyone is absolutely furious. And then on the 4th of October, he voices reservations about the Declaration of Rights. And I suppose the king would say, well, why shouldn't I? I'm the king. I can say what he likes. But in the context of a liberty-loving people with sovereignty, this is dangerous. And I think also there is a sense in Paris that the National Assembly itself is compromised by its willingness to treat with the king. And there's talk that they want to move it from Versailles and the Paris region to tour the city on the Loire, which is famously royalist and would kind of therefore get them out of the
封建权利的行为发表了评论，但他加上了如此多的限定条件，以至于听起来他实际上是在拒绝它。代表们对此非常不安。而在巴黎，每个人都绝对愤怒。然后在10月4日，他对《人权宣言》表示了保留意见。我想国王会说，好吧，我为什么不能？我是国王。我可以随心所欲地说。但在一个拥有主权的、热爱自由的人民的背景下，这是危险的。而且我认为巴黎有一种感觉，国民议会本身因为它愿意与国王打交道而受到损害。有传言说他们想把它从凡尔赛和巴黎地区搬到卢瓦尔河畔的图尔，那里以保皇派著称，因此会让他们摆脱
crosshairs of Parisian popular opinion. And they're not in favor of that at all. And the other thing that is happening in August and through into September, which everyone knows is incredibly problematic, both for those who are starving and those who have to keep a lid on things that are bubbling away in France, is the fact that the price of bread is starting to go up again. So it had declined kind of in early August, but it's now going up. And this isn't because there's terrible weather. The weather's very good. The grain is ripening. It's kind of ready to be harvested. But the problem is that the weather is so good that all the mills have been immobilized because there's no water in the rivers. So you start to get bread riots,
巴黎公众舆论的交叉火力。他们根本不支持这一点。而在8月和9月期间发生的另一件事，每个人都知道这对于那些挨饿的人和那些必须控制法国局势的人来说都是极其成问题的，那就是面包价格开始再次上涨。所以它在8月初有所下降，但现在正在上涨。这不是因为天气恶劣。天气非常好。谷物正在成熟。它已经准备好收割了。但问题是天气太好了，所有的磨坊都因为河流里没有水而无法运转。所以你开始看到面包骚乱，
you get demands for higher wages, and you get these familiar accusations, which the Marquis de Sade makes such play with in his novels, that the king and the aristocracy are deliberately trying to starve the revolution to death. It's a useful reminder, isn't it, that there are these two different dimensions to the revolution. So on the one hand, there's the dimension of kind of politics and ideas and everything that's going on in the National Assembly as people are moving into their different factions left and right. None of that would have the salience and it wouldn't be so charged were it not for the fact that outside there are people starving. There is a real anger on the streets, isn't there? And the danger, the huge danger for the authors of the revolution is that they've given people the impression that changes to the political and financial kind of
你听到对提高工资的要求，你听到这些熟悉的指控，萨德侯爵在他的小说中大肆渲染这些指控，即国王和贵族正在蓄意让革命饿死。这是一个有用的提醒，不是吗？革命有两个不同的维度。一方面，有政治和思想的维度，以及国民议会中正在发生的一切，因为人们正在进入他们不同的左派和右派派系。如果不是因为外面有人在挨饿，这一切都不会有如此的显著性和如此强烈的冲击力。革命的作者们面临的巨大危险是，他们给了人们一种印象，即政治和金融结构的改变会奇迹般地改变街头的情况，意味着面包价格下跌等等。而实际上他们中的许多人，他们是我们所说的“新自由主义者”。他们根本没有打算固定面包价格，帮助人们，做所有这些事情。是的，因为五月的激进分子可能是九月的保守派。正是如此。事情发展得太快了。所以人们感觉到许多代表就像在下行的自动扶梯上飞奔，只是试图避免自己被革命吞噬。而这被一个事实所加速，当然，那就是《人权宣言》已经正式废除了审查制度。这意味着基本上当局
structure will magically transform the situation on the streets and mean that bread prices fall and all that kind of thing. And actually a lot of them, they're what we would call neoliberals. They have no intention of fixing the price of bread and helping people out and doing all these kinds of things. Yeah, because May's radical could be September's conservative. Exactly. Things are moving so fast. So there's a sense that lots of deputies are kind of running very fast up a down escalator, just trying to kind of avoid themselves being chewed up by the revolution. And this is turbocharged by the fact, of course, that the Declaration of Rights has officially abolished censorship. And that means that there's basically nothing the authorities
无能为力来限制敌意的表达，无论是针对国王还是国民议会，还是其他任何人。有一份特别的报纸于9月12日创刊。所以，在所有这些事件的背景下，这确实证明了新闻业现在可以有多么强大。这是一份报纸，这不是它最初的名字，但它最终的名字是《人民之友》（L'Amie du Peuple），所以是“人民的朋友”。它的编辑是一个叫让-保罗·马拉的人，
can do to restrain expressions of hostility, whether it's to the King or to the National Assembly or whoever. And there is a particular newspaper which is launched on the 12th of September. So against the backdrop of all these events, which really, really demonstrates how potent journalism can now be. And this is a paper, it's not its original name, but its ultimate name is L'Amie du Peuple, so the People's Friend. And its editor is a man called Jean-Paul Marat,
他基本上，他有点从一份工作漂泊到另一份工作。他是一个从未真正拥有过稳定职位的人。他是一位科学家，一位医生。他是一位政治理论家。实际上，有一段时间，有点像我们的Goal Hanger同事阿兰·希勒，多米尼克。他住在纽卡斯尔。是的。
who is basically, he's kind of drifted from job to job. He's someone who's never really held down a secure position. He's a scientist, he's a physician. He's a political theorist. Actually, for a while, a bit like our goal hanger stablemate, Alan Shearer, Dominic. He lived in Newcastle. Yeah.
除了，我的意思是，阿兰·希勒从未成为阿图瓦伯爵保镖的医生，我不这么认为。阿兰·希勒也。我的意思是，你可以随心所欲地评价阿兰·希勒，但他有很好的皮肤。而马拉有糟糕的皮肤。马拉确实有非常糟糕的皮肤。而且，他从未写过关于他朋友淋病的论文，我想，阿兰·希勒。
Except, I mean, Alan Shearer never ended up physician to the bodyguard of the Comte d'Artois, I don't think. Alan Shearer also. I mean, you can say what you like about Alan Shearer, but he's got lovely skin. And Mara has terrible skin. Mara does have absolutely terrible skin. And also, he's never written a paper on the gonorrhea of one of his friends, I think, Alan Shearer.
据你所知，汤姆。你不知道他和克雷格·贝拉米或莱斯·费迪南德或他的任何纽卡斯尔同事在一起做了什么。所以马拉从圣詹姆斯公园回到巴黎。是的。他有点漂泊不定。他有点像个流浪汉。我的意思是，他是那种“薪水过低的知识分子”的典型例子，被低估的知识分子总是革命的伟大推动者。
As far as you know, Tom. You don't know about what he's been up to with Craig Bellamy or Les Ferdinand or any of his Newcastle stablemates. So Marat comes back from St. James's Park to Paris. Yeah. And he's kind of drifting around. He's a bit of a bum. I mean, he's the classic example of the, you know, the underpaid intellectual, the undervalued intellectual is always the great driver of revolutions.
而马拉就是那种典型的例子。他在革命中找到了编辑这份报纸《人民之友》的机会，这绝对是他为之而生的一切，你知道，这完全是他的天职。本质上，他非常擅长将一切归咎于阴谋、密谋、险恶人物试图摧毁人民的企图。所以他称他的敌人为“吸血鬼”，非常沉迷于那种吸血鬼的语言。当国民议会的代表们试图整理宪法时，他却像一个
And Marat's the kind of classic example. And he finds in the revolution and the chance to edit this paper, The People's Friend, absolutely everything that he's ever been made for, you know, it's completely his vocation. And essentially, he is brilliant at blaming everything on conspiracies, on plots, on attempts by sinister figures to destroy the people. So he calls his enemies bloodsuckers, very much into the kind of the language of vampirism. While the deputies in the National Assembly are trying to kind of the language of vampirism. While the deputies in the National Assembly are trying to kind of sort the constitution out, he's piling in full kind of
推特上的愤怒者一样全力以赴。所以睁开你的眼睛，摆脱你的冷漠，清洗你的委员会，只保留健康的成员，扫除腐败分子、皇家养老金领取者和狡猾的贵族、阴谋家和伪爱国者。除了奴役、贫困和荒凉，你对他们别无所求。马拉是一个如此熟悉的人物。他就是那种突然发现自己是个失败者的人，基本上，正如你所说的，一个流浪者。而在革命的混乱中，他突然看到了通过这种令人难以置信的凶猛谩骂来成名的机会。我的意思是，我们今天确实看到了像他这样的人，不是吗？我认为称他们为“中间派”并不是太大的时代错误。那些最初
angry person on Twitter. So open your eyes, shake off your lethargy, purge your committees, preserve only the healthy members, sweep away the corrupt, the royal pensioners and the devious aristocrats, intriguers and false patriots. You have nothing to expect from them except servitude, poverty and desolation. Marat is such a familiar figure. He's that person who suddenly sees he's been a loser, basically, and a drifter, as you said. And he's suddenly in the chaos of the revolution, sees his opportunity to make a name for himself by this unbelievably ferocious invective. I mean, we do see people like it today, don't we? I think it's not too much of an anachronism to call them centrists. People who initially had
支持革命，现在随着这种越来越激进的语言，开始想，哦，等等。所以这些通常是革命的外国崇拜者。所以有一位英国游客在巴黎，他来到这里是因为他对正在发生的事情感到非常兴奋，他正在关注这些对国民议会的攻击。他写道，祸哉，那个雇佣无知的放荡暴民来执行其法律的立法机构。灯柱是这个国家的论据。所以灯柱，你把绳子挂在上面，吊死你的敌人。是的，私刑，基本上。基本上是私刑，是的。所以你在这里有关于主权应该在哪里对立的观点。人民的主权是在街头上，还是在宪法形式中？这就是革命正在聚焦的伟大问题。
been in favour of the revolution and now with this kind of ever more radical language are starting to think, oh, hold on. So often these are foreign, foreign admirers of the revolution. So there's an English visitor in Paris who'd come there because he was kind of so excited by what was going on, who is following these kind of attacks on the National Assembly. And he writes, woe be to the legislature that employs a senseless profligate rabble to enforce its laws. Lanterns are arguments in this country. So lanterns, you sling a rope over it and hang your enemies. Yeah, lynching, basically. Basically lynching, yes. And so there you have opposed senses of where sovereignty should lie. Does the people's sovereignty lie on the streets or does it lie in kind of constitutional forms? And this is the great question that the revolution is kind of focusing.
正如7月初一样，9月进入10月，首都有一种潜在的暴力感，现在不仅针对王室，也针对国民议会，当然，他们都在凡尔赛。甚至在8月，你还有一位被关押在沙朗通的贵族，萨德侯爵被送到了那里。而这种萨德式的品质，我发现非常迷人。但无论如何，这是一位侯爵，他曾提议向凡尔赛进军，但这有点不了了之。但在奥尔良公爵（路易十六的堂兄）拥有的这个伟大的言论自由中心——皇家宫殿，许多激进圈子都在说我们应该组织一场政变。我们应该向凡尔赛进军。我们应该抓住王室。本质上，这座城市感觉它正处于进一步的革命热情或反革命之间。对于那些
And as in early July, so in September, moving into October, a sense of potential violence in the capital directed now, not just against the royal family, but also against the National Assembly, both of whom, of course, are in Versailles. And even in August, you had had an aristocrat who'd been imprisoned in Charenton, where the Marquis de Sade had been sent. And the kind of the Sadean quality of quite a lot of this is, I just find fascinating. But anyway, this is a Marquis and he had proposed a march on Versailles and that had kind of fizzled out. But in the Palais Royal, which is this kind of great center of free speech owned by the Duke of Orléans, the cousin of Louis XVI, lots of radical circles are saying we should organize a coup. We should march on Versailles. We should get the royal family. And essentially, the city feels that it is poised between further expressions of revolutionary fervour or counter-revolution. And for those who are in
负责阻止骚乱爆发的人来说，这是一场噩梦，因为你如何阻止它？好吧，这就是问题所在，对吧？为什么当局，我的意思是，他们有钱，他们有武装人员。为什么他们不以某种方式进行镇压并试图监管这一点？好吧，首先，正如你所说，存在审查制度的问题。他们无法控制现在正在说的话。所以就像1650年代的英国一样，革命孕育了言论自由，这反过来又促进了进一步的革命活动，所以这是其中的一部分，但另一件事是，如果你说权力结构是封建的，是某种吸血鬼式的表达，那么就很难
charge of stopping riots breaking out, this is a nightmare because how do you stop it? Well, this is the question, right? Why don't the authorities, I mean, they have money, they have armed men. Why don't they in some way clamp down and try and police this? Well, for starters, as you've said, there's the issue around censorship. They can't control what is now being said. So as in the 1650s in England, revolution has bred freedom of speech, which in turn fosters further revolution activity so that's one part of it but the other thing is is that if you were saying that the structures of power are feudal and expressions of a kind of blood-sucking vampirism very difficult
接管它们。所以所有这些都被抹去了，巴士底狱没了，密札（lettre de cachet）没了，所有这些都没了。所以本质上，在一个非常奥威尔式的步骤中，革命者发现他们必须复活他们所消除的东西。是的。而且有趣的是，他们这么早就这样做了，对吧？在1789年。所以，在巴士底狱陷落后的短短几个月内，在那年夏天结束时，在秋天，他们已经在想我们必须带回，他们称之为什么，调查委员会。所以他们正在拆开信件，做所有这类事情。是的。所以沙玛在《公民》一书中将其描述为革命警察国家的第一个器官。本质上，它为自己夺取了每个人都谴责的旧制度的所有权力。
to take charge of them so all of those have been erased the bastille has gone the letter cachet has gone all of that so essentially in a very kind of Orwellian step, the revolutionaries find that they have to resurrect what they have eliminated. Yeah. And it's interesting they're doing this so early, right? In 1789. So within just a couple of months, really, of the fall of the Bastille, at the end of that summer, in the autumn, they're already thinking we have to bring back, what do they call it, the search committee. So they're opening letters and doing all that kind of thing. Yeah. So Sharma in Citizens describes it as the first organ of a revolutionary police state. And essentially it takes for itself all the powers of the Ancien Régime that everyone had condemned.
所以他们可以拆开信件，他们可以资助间谍，他们可以不经搜查令搜查房屋。令人惊讶的是，他们甚至可以不经审判就监禁那些被怀疑对革命构成危险的人，这基本上就是整个密札系统。所以这是其中的一个方面。你有了某种秘密警察的发展。但当然，还有我们之前谈到的由拉法耶特指挥的国民卫队。他的工作本质上是维持首都的秩序。但他发现这越来越困难。你知道，他正在应对一个以前从未有人不得不应对的情况。好吧，你和我对拉法耶特的看法不同，不是吗？我认为如果他是一个更冷酷无情的人，他本可以抓住这个机会，真正成名。但他有点优柔寡断，你觉得这么说公平吗？不，我对他看法要好得多。我的意思是，他是革命的狂热者。他不是反革命分子，他正在应对一个
So they can open letters, they can sponsor spies, they can search houses without warrants. And amazingly, they can even imprison people who are suspected of being in danger to the revolution without trial, which is basically the whole letter to cachet system. So that's one aspect of it. You've got kind of the development of a kind of proto-secret police. But you also have the National Guard, of course, who we talked about before, commanded by Lafayette. And it's his job essentially to maintain order in the capital. But he's finding an increasing struggle. You know, he's coping with a situation that no one has ever had to cope with before. Well, you and I disagree about Lafayette, don't we? I think if he had been a man of greater cold-blooded ruthlessness, he could have seized this opportunity and really made a name for himself. But he's a bit of a ditherer, do you think it's fair to say? No, I look on him much more favorably. I mean, he's an enthusiast for the revolution. He's not a counter-revolutionary and he is struggling with a situation
以前从未有人真正面对过的情况。好吧，实际上，你知道吗，汤姆？有人以前面对过这种情况，而且正如我们将在本集后面看到的那样，人们将他与一位英国前任进行了比较，如果他有那位英国前任的一半骨气和精神，他有一天会成为法国的护国公，但事与愿违。可能吧。无论如何，所以9月转为10月，首都越来越准备好
that no one has really ever had to face before. Well, actually, do you know what, Tom? Somebody has faced this before and later on, as we will see in this episode, people compare him with an English predecessor and if he'd had anything like the backbone and the spirit of that English predecessor, he'd one day have been Lord Protector of France, but it wasn't to be. Possibly. Anyway, so September turns to October, capital's getting ever more ready to kind of blow
爆发。面包价格正在上涨。然后在10月2日，凡尔赛的一起丑闻细节传到了巴黎。而且一次又一次，我们一直在谈论凡尔赛的丑闻细节在影响事件进程方面有多么重要。这被视为绝对的震惊。所以马拉对此大肆渲染，《人民之友》，他喜欢这个。故事是国王从东北边境召集了一个团，佛兰德斯团。他们抵达了凡尔赛，他的保镖为他们举办了一场宴会。在巴黎人们挨饿的时候举办宴会，无论如何都被视为非常冒犯，但这场宴会据称演变成了一场由王后赞助的狂欢。最令人震惊的是，这场宴会的所有参与者
up. Price of bread is going up. And then on the 2nd of October, details of a scandal in Versailles arrives in Paris. And again and again, we've been talking about how important the details of a scandal in Versailles arrives in Paris. And again and again, we've been talking about how important the details of royal scandals are in affecting the course of events. And this is seen as an absolute shocker. So Marat is all over it, the people's friend, he loves this. And the story goes that the king has summoned a regiment from the northeast frontier, the Flanders Regiment. They've arrived in Versailles, and his bodyguard have staged a banquet for them. Staging a banquet at a time when people in Paris are starving is seen as being very offensive anyway, but this banquet is supposed to have degenerated into an orgy sponsored by the queen. Most shockingly of all, all the participants in
据称都拿起了革命的帽章，即三色旗，并将其践踏在脚下。而王后据称批准了这一切。在巴黎，这被视为一种亵渎。它加速了所有关于王后堕落、关于她那种贪婪的品质、她让巴黎穷人饿死的愿望的旧谣言，但它确实结合了两种不同的阴谋论，不是吗？一个是关于玛丽·安托瓦内特的，另一个是整个夏天和秋天，人们一直担心边境军队的到来。是的，特别是讲德语的军队，所以佛兰德斯团。对于这些人来说，他们认为这些人已经出现，他们将成为反革命的先锋。他们与宫廷里的吸血鬼勾结。我的意思是，这对于像马拉这样的人来说，再好不过了。
this banquet are supposed to have taken the revolutionary cascade, so the tricolour, and trampled it underfoot. And the queen is said to have approved of it all. And in Paris, this is seen as a kind of blasphemy. And it turbocharges all the old rumours that the queen of her depravity, of her kind of empiricic qualities her desire to starve the poor of paris to death but it combines two different conspiracy theories really doesn't it one is the thing about marianne so an empty mentioned but the other is all through the summer and the autumn people have been anxious about the arrival of troops from the frontiers yeah german-speaking troops in particular so the flanders regiment for these the idea that these people have turned up they're going to be the vanguard of the counter-revolution. They're in league with the bloodsuckers in the court. I mean, it could not be a better gift to somebody like Marat.
是的，它在巴黎最贫穷的地区散布了恐怖。在10月5日，清晨，一位市场妇女，她站了起来。她向所有开始为当天的市场聚集的妇女发表讲话。她向她们大声疾呼，说她们买不起面包，她们买不起食物放在家人的餐桌上，这是因为王后，因为凡尔赛的吸血鬼，她们应该向宫殿进军，好吧，谁知道会发生什么，但多米尼克，接下来发生的事情将永远改变法国的面貌。多么戏剧性，汤姆。我们现在要休息一下，因为我们太兴奋了。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
Yeah, and it spreads terror throughout the poorest quarters in Paris. And on the 5th of October, early in the morning, a market woman, she stands up. She addresses all the other women who have started gathering for the day's market. And she harangues them saying that the fact that they can't afford to get bread, that they can't afford to put food on their family's tables, that this is due to the queen, due to the vampires of Versailles, and they should march on the palace and well who knows what but what happens dominic will change the face of france forever what drama tom we're gonna take a break now because we're just too excited i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment
这是你每周的娱乐新闻评论，一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余味》，乌云已经聚集在凡尔赛上空，有人在喊王后是吸血鬼，佛兰德斯团在践踏人们的帽章，一切都在发生，然而汤姆，凡尔赛的悲剧是，国王和王后在他们简单的快乐中，完全不知道即将发生的事情。就好像革命从未发生过一样。
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The rest is history the storm clouds have gathered over versailles there are people shouting about the queen being a vampire and the flanges regiment treading down people's cockades it's all happening and yet tom the tragedy in versailles the king and queen are about their simple pleasures in complete obliviousness to what is coming. It's as though the revolution had never happened.
那天早上，玛丽·安托瓦内特在她的微型模范村，小特里亚农宫。她一直在喂她的鸭子，喂她的金鱼。然后她对此感到有点累了。所以她退到一个石窟里休息一下。哦，那很好。田园诗般的。她的丈夫，国王，一直在外面射击。通常他会去打猎，但他意识到巴黎正在酝酿麻烦。
So that morning, Marie Antoinette is in her little model village, the Petit Trianon. She's been feeding her ducks, feeding her goldfish. And then she's been left a bit tired by this. And so she retires to a grotto for a little rest. Oh, that's nice. Bucolic. Her husband, the king, has been out shooting. Normally he would have gone hunting, but he is aware that trouble is brewing in Paris.
所以通过去射击，这意味着他可以，如果事态发展，更容易联系到他。他度过了非常成功的一天射击。是的。在他的日记中，他记录道，杀了81头。按照弗朗茨·斐迪南和乔治五世的标准，表现很差。绝对是。但我认为对于一个早晨来说还不错。是的，这就是奥地利人和法国人的区别，不是吗？
And so by going shooting, it means that he can be, it's easier to contact him should developments happen. And he has a very successful day shooting. Yeah. And in his journal, he notes, killed 81 head. A poor show by the standards of Franz Ferdinand and George V. Absolutely. But I think not bad for a morning. Yeah, that's the difference between the Austrians and the French, isn't it?
奥地利人是如此无情。好吧，这当然是巴黎的暴民在谈论玛丽·安托瓦内特时会说的话。当然，这两种活动都绝对是为了激怒有道德的爱国者，因为玛丽·安托瓦内特在小特里亚农宫和她的动物玩耍，我的意思是，这在某种程度上将成为她定义的形象。角色扮演，这被视为轻浮。我的意思是，我们谈到了我认为玛丽·安托瓦内特将其视为她对穷人同情的表达，但这并不是穷人自己看待它的方式。而国王去射击，同样，这在某种程度上是故意冒犯，因为作为已被抛弃的封建特权之一，是贵族拥有的去射击的权利。
The Austrians are so ruthless. Well, that's certainly what the mobs in Paris would say when they talk about Marie Antoinette. And of course, both of these activities are absolutely calculated to infuriate virtuous patriots because Marie Antoinette playing with her animals in the Petit Trianon, I mean, this will become, in a way, the defining image of her. The role playing, it's seen as feckless. I mean, we talked about how I think Marie Antoinette sees it as an expression of her sympathy with the poor, but this is not how the poor themselves see it. And the king going shooting, again, this is kind of deliberately offensive because as one of the feudal privileges that have been jettisoned is the right that the
所以随着对狩猎和射击的封建垄断的废除，基本上法国的每一只鸟都被消灭了。所以你可能会抱怨国王射击的鸟不够多，但我的意思是，在整个法国，到处都是砰、砰、砰。我们的老朋友，一直在法国各地旅行的英国人阿瑟·杨，我们在这个系列中大量借鉴了他的日记，他在普罗旺斯时，突然每个人去射击都变得合法了。他说，我被所有去射击的乡村暴民纠缠。人们会认为普罗旺斯每一支生锈的枪都在工作，杀死各种各样的鸟。
nobility had to go shooting. And so with the abolition of the feudal monopolies on hunting and shooting, basically every bird in France has been wiped out. So you may complain that the king hasn't been shooting enough birds, but I mean, all over France, it's just bang, bang, bang. And our old friend, Arthur Young, the Englishman who's been traveling across France and who's journalists we've been drawing on a lot for this series, he's in Provence when suddenly it becomes legal for everyone to go out shooting. And he says, I've been pestered with all the mob of the country shooting. One would think that every rusty gun in Provence is at work, killing all sorts of birds.
贵族必须去打猎。因此，随着封建狩猎和射击垄断权的废除，法国几乎所有的鸟类都被消灭殆尽。所以你可能会抱怨国王打的鸟不够多，但我的意思是，在整个法国，到处都是砰、砰、砰的枪声。我们的老朋友，那位游历法国并为本系列节目提供了大量日记素材的英国人阿瑟·杨，当时正在普罗旺斯，突然间每个人都可以合法地去打猎了。他说，我被乡下那群打猎的暴民烦透了。人们会以为普罗旺斯每一把生锈的枪都在开火，杀死了各种各样的鸟。
The shot has fallen five or six times in my chase and about my ears so that's something that hasn't changed really in france that's still very much going on but you know dominic this is the last time the king will have the option of choosing whether to go shooting or hunting and it will be the last time that the queen will get to feed her ducks at the petty tree and all the ducks are the real losers and all that don't they because they end up being eaten by son culottes i imagine they'll be shot yes so as louis notes in his journal interrupted by events and that of course is his shooting journal so 10 o'clock in the morning marianne trinette is reposing in her grotto when she is informed that an armed force has left Paris and is marching on Versailles. And brilliantly, she's informed by her hairdresser.
在我的追逐中，枪声在我耳边响了五六次，所以法国的情况确实没有什么改变，这种事依然在发生。但你知道吗，多米尼克，这是国王最后一次有权选择去打猎还是射击了，也是王后最后一次能在小特里亚农宫喂她的鸭子了。所有的鸭子都是真正的输家，不是吗？因为我想它们最终会被无套裤汉吃掉，或者被射杀。是的，正如路易在日记中记录的那样，他被事件打断了，当然，那是他的狩猎日记。早上10点，玛丽·安托瓦内特正在她的石窟里休息，这时她接到通知，一支武装力量已经离开巴黎，正向凡尔赛进军。而且非常巧妙的是，她是听她的理发师说的。
Is that right? Monsieur Léonard. Monsieur Léonard, who is the sort of the metrosexual friend of Marie Antoinette, isn't he? Yes, well, that's what he later says. It has to be said that this is uncorroborated by anyone else. But yes, absolutely. Coming to the rescue of his diva friend. Trickier to get in touch with Louis XVI because he's out shooting.
是这样吗？莱昂纳尔先生。莱昂纳尔先生，他是玛丽·安托瓦内特那种都市美男式的朋友，对吧？是的，嗯，这是他后来自己说的。必须指出的是，这一点没有得到其他任何人的证实。但确实，绝对是这样。他来拯救他那位天后朋友了。要联系路易十六就比较棘手了，因为他出去打猎了。
But they find him and he is back by three o'clock in the afternoon. And there's a meeting of the Royal Council and they don't know what to do. And there is discussion that perhaps the king and queen should, I don't know, head for the frontier, head for somewhere secure. But what's fascinating is that even at this stage, the king is thinking in terms of a factional court politics because he blames the Duke of Orléans, who owns the Palais Royal, where all these kind of radicals are meeting. It's as though he still hasn't got the hang of the fact that this is no longer about dukes conspiring against their cousins, but about something much profounder. But here's the interesting thing, I guess. He is so ill-travelled, he's only ever been out of the Versailles kind of bubble really twice, hasn't he?
但他们找到了他，他在下午三点前回来了。皇家委员会召开了一次会议，他们不知道该怎么办。有人讨论说，也许国王和王后应该，我不知道，前往边境，去某个安全的地方。但令人着迷的是，即使在这个阶段，国王考虑的还是派系宫廷政治，因为他责怪奥尔良公爵，公爵拥有巴黎皇家宫殿，而那些激进分子都在那里聚会。就好像他还没搞清楚，这不再是公爵们密谋反对他们的表亲，而是涉及更深层的东西。但我猜，有趣的是这一点：他去过的地方太少了，他离开凡尔赛那个“泡沫”其实只有两次，不是吗？
He went for his coronation and he went to Cherbourg to inspect some defences. So he's very poorly, I mean, he's been to his palace in Paris, the Tuileries, but he doesn't have any sense of what is going on. So how could he understand, I guess, the anger on the streets and all of that kind of thing? It would take a profound political imagination to grasp that, and he is a very unimaginative man. And Marie Antoinette, I think, is the same,
他去参加了自己的加冕礼，还去瑟堡视察了一些防御工事。所以他见识非常有限，我是说，他去过他在巴黎的宫殿——杜伊勒里宫，但他对正在发生的事情毫无感知。所以我想，他怎么可能理解街头的愤怒以及诸如此类的事情呢？这需要深刻的政治想象力才能领会，而他是一个非常缺乏想象力的人。我认为玛丽·安托瓦内特也是一样，
that for her, crowds are a kind of background for the display of her own magnificence. And she simply has no comprehension of what they might be feeling, what the kind of individual components of those crowds might be like. So for both of them, it's really difficult. And even for the members of the National Assembly, they don't know what is coming. They're not sure what to expect. Who is coming from Paris? Why? What do they want? And it takes time for them to kind of properly appreciate what's going on. So to that question, who is coming? There are basically three groups of people. There is the market women of Paris, the fishwives. And there
对她来说，人群只是展示她自身华丽背景的一种衬托。她根本无法理解他们可能有什么感受，也无法理解那些人群中的个体成分是什么样的。所以对他们两人来说，这真的很难。即使对于国民议会的成员来说，他们也不知道接下来会发生什么。他们不确定该期待什么。谁从巴黎来了？为什么？他们想要什么？他们需要时间来正确评估正在发生的事情。所以对于那个问题，谁来了？基本上有三群人。巴黎的菜市场妇女，卖鱼的妇人。而
it's been escalating very quickly since the one woman stood up and said, we should march on Versailles. One of the women gets hold of a drum and she starts beating it. And then they get the bells of a nearby church to start ringing. So it kind of talks in ringing out. Huge crowd forms. They start to march on the Hotel de Ville. They are chanting the title of a particularly popular pamphlet, When Will We Have Bread? They start reaching for cudgels, for sticks, for knives, any kind of weapon that they can get. By the time these various groups converge on the Hotel de Ville, there are about 6,000 or 7,000 of them, and they absolutely ransack it, seizing it for muskets, for rifles, for whatever they can get. They even find two cannon.
自从一个女人站出来说“我们应该向凡尔赛进军”之后，事态升级得非常快。其中一个女人拿过一面鼓开始敲打。然后他们让附近教堂的钟声响起来。所以它就像在回荡。庞大的人群形成了。他们开始向市政厅进军。他们高喊着一本特别受欢迎的小册子的标题：“我们什么时候才能有面包？”他们开始抓起棍棒、木棍、刀子，任何他们能拿到的武器。当这些不同的群体汇聚到市政厅时，大约有六七千人，他们彻底洗劫了那里，抢夺火枪、步枪，任何他们能拿到的东西。他们甚至发现了两门大炮。
So this is, again, kind of quite like the Bastille, a huge mob looking for weapons. By this point, it is pouring down with rain. And normally rain is, you know, rain is what stops revolutions, but not in this case. Despite the rain, the women with their two cannon and all their weapons and their cudgels and things start heading off for Versailles. Can I just interrupt at this point, Tom? So the interesting thing about them heading to Versilles so these women the sort of fishwise market women they were known as poissard and they would go to versailles every year anyway they used
所以这又有点像攻占巴士底狱，一大群暴民在寻找武器。此时此刻，正下着倾盆大雨。通常雨是，你知道的，雨是会阻止革命的，但这次不是。尽管下着雨，那些带着两门大炮和所有武器、棍棒之类的妇女开始向凡尔赛进发。汤姆，我能在这里打断一下吗？关于她们前往凡尔赛的有趣之处在于，这些妇女，也就是那些卖鱼的菜市场妇女，她们被称为“poissard”，她们每年都会去凡尔赛，她们习惯于
to go to versailles on the 25th of august the feast of saint louis and they would give flowers to the queen so it was a kind of ritual and so she was used to seeing them and she actually you know you were saying about the thing with the petit trianon and pretending feeding the ducks and pretending you know to be an ordinary farm girl and stuff yeah they would do plays of versailles where they would affect the dialect of the fish wives and these were very common in france the fish wives they were stock figures they were laughing stock i guess and marie an Antoinette herself had kind of got people to try and teach her their lingo and stuff. So there is a dreadful irony at the back of all this. There is. And that is exactly the tension between Marie Antoinette's understanding of what a crowd should be and what a crowd might actually be is part of what makes the whole experience that is
在8月25日圣路易节那天去凡尔赛，她们会给王后送花，所以这是一种仪式，她习惯了见到她们。而且实际上，你刚才提到小特里亚农宫的事情，假装喂鸭子，假装自己是一个普通的农家女孩之类的，是的，她们会在凡尔赛表演戏剧，模仿卖鱼妇人的方言，这些在法国很常见，卖鱼妇人是典型的形象，我想她们是笑柄，而玛丽·安托瓦内特本人也曾让人试着教她她们的黑话之类的。所以这一切背后有一种可怕的讽刺。确实有。而这正是玛丽·安托瓦内特对人群应该是什么样子的理解，与人群实际上可能是什么样子之间的张力，这正是让整个经历变得如此令她痛苦的原因。我不认为这些妇女对王后的态度有任何矛盾。我认为她们对她几乎是普遍敌视的，原因就是我们一直在讨论的那些。对路易的态度则稍微矛盾一些。她们称他为“好爸爸”（Le Bon Papa），她们希望他给她们面包。不清楚她们称他为“好爸爸”是出于敌意、一种讽刺感，还是她们真心实意地这么认为。可能存在一个灰色地带，她们无法确定他到底是敌人还是朋友。但可以肯定的是，她们也说，如果他是“好爸爸”，他就应该和他的孩子们待在
coming so completely traumatic for her. And I don't think there's any ambivalence in the attitude of the women towards the queen. I think they are pretty universally hostile to her for all the reasons that we've been discussing. Attitudes to Louis is a slightly more ambivalent. So they're calling him Le Bon Papa, the good father, and they want him to give them bread. And it's unclear whether they are calling him Le Bon Papa out of hostility, kind of sense of irony, or whether they genuinely mean it. And it may be that there's a kind of gray area where they can't quite decide whether he is the enemy or their friend. But definitely, they are also saying that if he is Le Bon Papa, he should be with his children in
巴黎，而不是困在凡尔赛。随着她们向宫殿进发，这越来越成为她们谈论的一部分。在前进的过程中，她们也开始带上大量的男人。在路上，她们遇到了一支佛兰德军团的队伍。她们对此感到紧张，因为佛兰德军团被视为君主制的伟大捍卫者，但佛兰德军团的人都支持她们。这些人就是被指控践踏了帽徽的人，但实际上他们成了革命的狂热支持者，他们迎接游行队伍并说：“太棒了，我们和你们在一起。万岁，让我们向凡尔赛进发吧。”这是国王无法信任自己军队这一常见问题的表现。嗯，因为军队也是人。
Paris, not stuck out in Versailles. And this increasingly becomes part of what they're talking about as they head out to the palace. And as they go, they start picking up large numbers of men as well. And on their way, they meet with a contingent of the Flanders Regiment. And they're nervous about this because the Flanders Regiment is seen as the great defenders of the monarchy, but the Flanders Regiment, they're all in favor of it. These are the people who have been accused of trampling the placade, but actually they turn out to be great enthusiasts for the revolution and they greet the marchers and they say, brilliant, we're with you. Hooray, let's crack on to Versailles. And this is an expression of a familiar problem that the king can't trust his own troops. Well, because troops are people too.
他们也饿，他们对权威感到不耐烦，他们会说：“是啊，为什么不呢？其实这很有趣，让我们一起去凡尔赛吧。”你知道，军队从革命一开始就已经违抗军官好几个月了。是的，而且我认为，如果你受到像龙骑兵那样的残酷纪律约束，或者如果你正在挨饿，无法养活你的孩子（就像许多妇女那样），那么去凡尔赛远征的机会，即使下着倾盆大雨，也是一件令人兴奋的事情。汤姆，这在所有的革命和骚乱中其实都非常重要，而且我认为
They're hungry. They're impatient with authority. And they're like, yeah, why not? Actually, this is great fun let's all go to versailles you know and troops have been disobeying their officers since the very beginning of the revolution for months yeah and i think the fact that it is fun if you're subject to kind of brutal discipline as dragoons are or if you're starving and hungry and you can't feed your children as so many of the women are quite aside from anything else the chance to have a kind of expedition to versailles even if it's pissing down with rain, it's something exciting. It's so important in all revolutions and riots, actually, Tom, and something that I think
历史学家有时会低估这一点，即我认为任何起义、任何叛乱、任何骚乱的动力中，关键点之一就是那种狂欢节的感觉，我想，觉得这非常有趣。而且实际上，是的，让我们去吧。那种动力和那种眩晕感。你真的能感觉到，对吧？她们越接近凡尔赛，加入她们的人就越多，因为这是一个了不起的场合。
historians sometimes underplay is exactly this point, that one of the key things I always think in the momentum of any uprising, any rebellion, any riot, is the sense of the carnivalesque, I guess, of it being a tremendous laugh. And actually, yeah, let's go for it. And the momentum and the giddiness of it all. And you really get that sense, don't you? The closer they get to Versailles, more and more people are joining them because this is a tremendous occasion.
我不想，谁知道会发生什么？让我们加入这一切。更多的妇女。有一个女人看起来很惊人，骑在一种……她叫什么名字？是的，那个亚马逊女战士，而且这里有一种角色扮演的感觉，我想她戴着羽毛帽，穿着红色骑马装，腰间别着很多手枪，带着剑，她在马上显得英姿飒爽，她将永远被铭记为这次妇女游行的标志性人物，尽管她不是卖鱼妇。我是说，首先她有一匹马。
And I don't want to, who knows what's going to happen? Let's pile in kind of all this. More women. There's a woman who looks amazing on a kind of what's her name yeah so the amazon and again there's a kind of sense of cosplay there i think she's wearing a plumed hat she's got a red riding coat she's got loads of pistols in her belt she's got swords she's cuts a tremendous dash on her horse and she will always be kind of remembered as the emblematic figure of this march of the women even though though she is not a fishwife. I mean, she's got a horse for starters.
但那种正在发生的事情带有一点狂欢节色彩的感觉。我认为如果只是妇女游行，甚至加上佛兰德军团的成员，也不会像后来对国民议会和国王那样令人震惊。因为最终向凡尔赛进军的另一群人是国民自卫军。在拉法耶特的领导下，他本应在巴黎维持秩序，他们比菜市场妇女晚了五个小时向凡尔赛进军。这不是拉法耶特的主意。他基本上对他的手下想要出去加入妇女向凡尔赛进军的行列感到震惊，因为他立刻明白，这是一种完全不同的
But the sense that there is a slightly carnivalesque quality to what is happening. I think that if it was just the women marching and even members of the Flanders Regiment, it wouldn't be quite as alarming as it turns out to be for the National Assembly and for the King, because the other group of people who end up marching on Versailles is the National Guard. So under Lafayette, who was supposed to be keeping order in Paris, and they are marching on Versailles five hours behind the market women. This is not Lafayette's doing. He's basically appalled that his men want to go out and join the women on the March on Versailles, because he immediately understands that this is an altogether different
起义性质，而不是一群卖鱼妇去巴黎。让官方授权的巴黎卫队这样做，我的意思是，那是非常、非常具有威胁性的革命活动，是对宪法和君主制的敌意表达，拉法耶特作为一个中间派老爸，并不想卷入其中，但他基本上别无选择，因为我觉得他有一种感觉，如果他不顺从他的手下，他们要么会开小差，要么会杀了他，或者你知道，不会有什么好结果。是的，所以他与其郁郁寡欢，不如骑上马，带头冲了出去，当时还在下着大雨。他身后有15000名卫兵。所以这是一个巨大的数字
quality of insurrection to a bunch of fishwives going out to Paris. To have the officially mandated guard in Paris do that, I mean, that is very, very kind of menacing revolutionary activity, an expression of hostility to the constitution and to the monarchy which lafayette is sufficiently a centrist dad not to want to be involved in but basically he has very little choice because i think he has the feeling that if he doesn't go along with his men they'll either desert or murder him or you know nothing good will come of it yeah so rather than morosely he gets onto his horse and kind of rides out of their head and it's still driving rain. He's got 15,000 of the guard behind him. So that's an enormous number
的人群。他出发了，一位目击者形容他是“他自己军队的囚徒”，这实际上就是他的处境。所以现在你有两群人。你有妇女，还有国民自卫军，都在向凡尔赛进发。所以妇女先到达。她们试图闯入凡尔赛宫本身，但国王的保镖和瑞士卫队把她们挡了回去。于是她们向国民议会进军，闯入其中，要求见国王。顺便说一句，关于她们在国民议会的描述非常惊人，因为她们浑身湿透。绝对是湿透了，有点臭。
of people. And he heads off and one witness describes him as the prisoner of his own troops, which effectively is what he is. So you now have two groups of people. You have the women and you have the National Guard, both descending on Paris. So the women arrive first. They try and break into the Palace of Versailles itself, but the king's bodyguards and the Swiss Guard turn them back. So then they march on the National Assembly and they invade it and they demand to see the king. There are amazing descriptions of them in the National Assembly, by the way, because they're sodden. Absolutely drenched, kind of smelly.
她们进来时简直像在冒热气。你说那些大都市精英代表，基本上他们都是，他们都是律师之类的，不是吗？坐在那里感到非常尴尬、恐惧和不安，他们中的许多人，当这大群人闯入议会，人们开始像摆弄代表们的东西，还有那种在他们耳边大喊大叫。我的意思是，他们就像那种，你知道，在湖区徒步旅行的人。他们全都闯了进来，浑身湿透，冒着热气。所以代表们派了一名信使去见国王，国王现在回来了，他们说：“看，您能接见一个妇女代表团吗？”他说：“当然可以。”所以妇女们选择了最完美的人
They're literally like steaming as they come in. And you said the metropolitan elite kind of delegates, which basically they all are, they're all lawyers and stuff, aren't they? Are sitting there kind of incredibly awkward and frightened and disturbed, a lot of them, as this great mob of people breaks into the Assembly and people start like messing around with the deputies' stuff and all that kind of shouting in their ears. I mean, they're like a kind of, you know, walking holiday in the Lake District. They've all kind of burst in, absolutely drenched and steaming. So the deputies send a messenger to the king who's back now and they say, look, would you receive a delegation of the women? And he says, yes, of course. So the women choose the perfect person
去和他谈话，那是一个17岁的卖花女，名叫皮埃雷特·沙布里斯。她非常害羞，非常漂亮，看起来非常贤惠，这很重要。而且她说话不像卖鱼妇。她以言谈举止文雅而闻名。所以她被选为发言人。她走上前，看着国王，她太激动了，以至于晕倒了，国王随后拿来嗅盐帮她站起来，这真是了不起的公关。然后他向妇女们解释说，他已经下令将任何被阻挡在通往巴黎道路上的粮食作为绝对紧急事项运送，他会尽力为她们寻找更多的粮食。
to speak to him, which is a 17-year-old flower girl called Pierrette Chabris. She's very shy, very pretty, very virtuous looking, which is very important. And she doesn't speak like a fishwife. She is renowned for her kind of genteel language. So she has chosen the spokeswoman. She goes forward, she looks at the king and she's so overwhelmed that she faints and the king then fetches her smelling salts helps her to her feet it's all tremendous pr he then explains to the women that he's given orders for any grain that has been held up on the roads leading into paris to be delivered as a matter of absolute urgency that he'll do his best to source them more grain
妇女们有点被安抚了，但路易即使如此也知道，他现在正面临枪口。所以那天晚上，不出所料，他最终毫无保留地接受了废除封建制度和《人权宣言》。据说当他签署批准时，他眼含热泪。但汤姆，这只是第一批人。确实。因为还有15000名男人也在路上。是的。
and the women are kind of mollified but louis knows even so that you know he is staring down a barrel here and so that evening unsurprisingly he finally accepts both the abolition of feudalism and the declaration of rights without any qualification whatsoever and it is said that as he you know he signs his approval he does so with tears in his eyes. But Tom, this is just the first group. It is. Because 15,000 men are also on their way. Yeah.
他们并不是真的，我是说，拉法耶特现在基本上是他们的战利品，而不是他们的指挥官。他们比菜市场妇女更可怕，不是吗？他们确实是。而且他们绝对决心把国王和王后带回去。当拉法耶特到达时，他去了国民议会，向他们解释了这一点，然后他要求觐见已经退回宫殿的国王，国王派出一名信使说：“是的，你可以进来，但你必须手无寸铁。”拉法耶特同意了，于是
And they're not really, I mean, Lafayette is now basically their trophy rather than their commander. And they are a much more terrifying prospect than the market women are, aren't they? They are. And they are absolutely set on bringing the king and queen back. And when Lafayette arrives, he goes the national assembly he explains this to them and he then demands an audience with the king who has retreated to the palace and the king sends a messenger out says yeah you can come in but you have to be unarmed and lafayette agrees to this and so a courtier
一位侍从，你知道，侍从长来了，他被带进了宫殿。多米尼克，你在上半场结束时提到了这一点。当他进去时，一位朝臣看到拉法耶特走进宫殿，说：“奥利弗·克伦威尔来了。”拉法耶特转过身说：“克伦威尔可不会手无寸铁地来。”所以你可能觉得这证明了你所说的。但我认为值得停下来想一想。拉法耶特在这里确实有一个巨大的机会。他是美国战争的英雄。
comes that you know chamberlain comes and him, and he is led into the palace. And Dominic, you referenced this in the end of the first half. As he goes in, a courtier sees Lafayette walking into the palace and says, there goes Oliver Cromwell. And Lafayette turns around and says, Cromwell would not have come unarmed. So you may feel that that proves what you're saying. But this is, I think it's worth just stopping a second. Lafayette does have a tremendous opportunity here. He is a hero of the American war.
他可以说是法国最著名的两三个人之一。他指挥着数万名士兵，潜在地。换一个人，比如拿破仑或克伦威尔，可能会把它变成一个权力基地，一个真正冷酷、精明的政治操盘手，但拉法耶特实际上没有这样做。我认为他没有这样做是他的功劳。当然你会这么想，当然你这么认为，但我不是，我认为他是一个中间派老爸，他正试图确保中间立场能够维持，他正在尽力而为，但我们知道那不会成功。但我认为他坚持自己的原则是他的功劳，尽管到最后他手里没剩下多少枪。是的，他
He is arguably one of the two or three most famous men in France. He has under his command tens of thousands of men, potentially. A different man, a Napoleon or a Cromwell, could have turned that into a power base, a really ruthless, hard-nosed political operator and actually lafayette doesn't i think it's to his credit that he doesn't of course you do of course you think that but i mean i don't i think that he's he's a centrist dad and he is trying to ensure that the center holds and he's doing his best but we know that that is not going to succeed but i think it's to his credit that he as it were sticks to his guns even though he will end up with not many guns by the end of the day effectively yeah he
没有坚持自己的枪，他让别人拿走了。不管怎样，告诉我们当他进去见国王时发生了什么。所以他像那些妇女一样，你知道，他湿透了，身上溅满了泥，他简直是一幅画。他来到路易面前，你知道，脱下帽子，行礼之类的。他用响亮的声音宣布：“我来是为了死在陛下的脚下。”显然是预先准备好的。同样，我想这会让你更加鄙视他。我喜欢它。我喜欢一个准备好戏剧性声明的人。不，我是说，你必须准备。不管怎样，继续。所以拉法耶特然后，他向国王重申：“看，你必须……”不管怎样，继续，所以拉法耶特然后，他向国王重申：“看，你必须
doesn't stick to his guns he lets other people take them and anyway tell us what happens when he gets in to see the king so he like the women is you know he's drenched he's spattered with mud he's an absolute picture he comes into the into louis presence and you know takes off his hat sweeps all this kind of thing. And he declares in ringing tones, I have come to die at the feet of your majesty. Obviously pre-prepared. Again, I imagine that this will confirm you in your sense of contempt for him. I like it. I like a man who prepares a melodramatic statement. No, I mean, you've got to prepare. Anyway, go on. So Lafayette then kind of, he reiterates to the king, look, you've got to get so anyway go on so lafayette then kind of he reiterates to the king look you've got
尽可能多地把粮食运到首都，陛下，恐怕你必须和我以及国民自卫军一起回巴黎。国民自卫军不会接受任何其他方式。”他同意了第一个请求，我是说，他已经下令将所有能找到的粮食尽快运往巴黎，但他确实在第二个请求上拖延了，他说：“看，我得和王后商量一下。”而玛丽·安托瓦内特已经上床睡觉了。所以这得留到早上。就在这些条件下，拉法耶特和国王分开了。所以国王大约两点钟上床睡觉。拉法耶特留在那儿。他想确保不会出什么乱子。但大约五点钟，他觉得，
to get as much grain to the capital as you possibly can and your majesty i'm afraid that you have to come with with me and the national guard back to paris the national guard are not going to have it any other way he agrees to the first request i mean he's you know he's already given orders that all the grain that can possibly be found be sent to paris as soon as possible but he does stonewall the second and he says look i'm going to have to consult with the queen. And Marie Antoinette has already gone to bed. So we'll have to be left to the morning. And on these terms, Lafayette and the king part. So the king goes to bed about two o'clock. Lafayette stays there. He wants to make sure that there's not going to be any trouble. But by about five o'clock, he feels,
“好吧，夜晚过去了。黎明快到了。我大概可以去小睡一会儿。”所以他娶了诺耶家族的一员。记得吗？我记得。他们在凡尔赛有一座大房子。所以他去了那里，找了一张沙发，蜷缩起来睡了一觉。
okay, so the night's passed. It's just before dawn. I could probably go and grab a few a few winks. So he is married to a member of the Noye family. Remember? I do. They have a big house in Versailles. So he goes off there and he finds a sofa and curls up and has a sleep.
我的意思是，这就是典型的拉法耶特，对吧？这绝对是教科书式的。我在凡尔赛，带着一大群15000人，他们完全失控了。我想我还是去小睡一会儿，躺一会儿吧。能出什么错呢？作为一个喜欢睡觉的人，我对他只有同情，但你是对的，这结果证明不是一个高明的举动，因为在拉法耶特离开大约半小时后，黎明时分，这是一个雾蒙蒙的早晨，一部分人群，也就是卖鱼妇和国民自卫军士兵的混合体，终于闯入了皇宫。是的，他们说的第一件事是：“王后的公寓在哪里？”他们说：“我们要用她的肠子做个帽徽。”还有人
I mean, that is Lafayette to a T, right? That is absolutely textbook. I'm in Versailles with a huge mob of 15,000 men who are kind of totally out of control. I think I'll just go for a little nap now and have a lie down. What could go wrong? As a man who likes to sleep, I have nothing but sympathy, but you are right that this turns out not to have been a brilliant move because about half an hour after Lafayette has gone it's dawn it's a kind of misty morning a portion of the crowd which is kind of intermingled fish wives and soldiers of the national guard finally break into the royal palace yeah and the first thing they say is where are the apartments of the queen they're saying we want to make a cocade out of her intestines. And others are
说：“我们要砍下她的头。我们要炸了她的心和肝，吃掉它们。我们要做的还不止这些。”更糟的是什么？谁知道呢？谁知道呢？所以他们冲向王后的公寓。门口站着两个保镖。他们被砍倒、杀害、斩首。这就是我们在本集开头阅读中提到的出现在长矛上的头颅。有第三个保镖。他设法提醒了一位侍女，她冲去叫醒王后。他随后被砍倒，被认为已经死了，尽管令人惊讶的是，他实际上活了下来。与此同时，玛丽·安托瓦内特被从床上叫醒，她赤着脚，看起来她被困在公寓里，但令人惊讶且幸运的是，早在1775年，她就下令建造了一条秘密通道，从她的
saying, we want to decapitate her. We want to fry up her heart and liver, eat them. And we want to do even worse. What's worse? Who knows? Who knows? So they descend on the queen's apartments. There are two bodyguards standing outside. They get cut down, killed, decapitated. These are the heads that will appear on the pikes that are mentioned in the reading that we began this episode with. There's a third bodyguard. He manages to alert a lady-in-waiting who rushes off to wake up the queen. He is then cut down and left for dead, although amazingly, actually, he survives. Marie Antoinette, meanwhile, she's been got out of bed, she's barefoot, and it seems like she's stuck in her apartment, but amazingly and fortuitously for her, way back in 1775, she had ordered the construction of a secret tunnel that would go from her
公寓通往国王的公寓，因为那时她急于确立自己对路易的影响力。所以她能够利用这一点，通道隐藏在镶板里。所以它在她身后关上了，她冲了出去，当她到达国王的寝宫时，敲了敲门，没有人回答，她穿着睡袍，赤着脚。是的，她因恐惧而啜泣，这是最令人难以置信的场景。与此同时，在她的卧室里，闯入的人对她不在那里感到非常愤怒，于是他们开始用剑劈砍她的床垫。而玛丽·安托瓦内特一直在敲门说：“求求你们，求求你们让我进去。”最终，有人听到了并打开了门，她跌跌撞撞地进去了。据说
appointments to the King's apartments because this was a time when she was anxious to establish her influence over Louis. And so she is able to use that and the passageway is kind of concealed in the panelling. so it shuts behind her and she goes rushing off as she reaches the king's quarters knocks on the door and there's no answer and she's in her nightgown and she's barefoot yeah and she's sobbing with terror the most unbelievable scene and meanwhile back in her bedroom the people who've broken in are absolutely infuriated that she's not there and so they start slashing at her mattress with their swords. And all the while, Marie Antoinette is hammering on the door saying, please, please let me in. And finally, someone hears and opens the door and she stumbles in. And it's said that
这次经历的恐惧太大了，以至于她的头发，之前是金色的，从这一点开始，鬓角的底部变白了。对。关于这一点有几件事。你描述了那两个保镖的场景，我们刚才只是用一句话带过了，但那是一个可怕的场景，对吧？我是说，一群暴民基本上抓住了这两个家伙，用刀把他们砍死，然后用刀锯下他们的头，我的意思是，这又是一个非常恐怖的场景。是的，所以我认为如果他们抓住了玛丽·安托瓦内特，她绝对会死。毫无疑问。
the terror of this experience is so great that her hair, which previously had been blonde, from this point on, the bottoms go white at the temples. Right. So a couple of things on this. One you described that scene of the the two bodyguards in a way we just sort of went through that in a sentence but that is a horrendous scene right i mean a mob basically grabbing these two guys hacking them to death with knives and then sawing off their heads with the knives i mean again a really horrific scene yeah and so i think it could absolutely have have spiraled hideously out of control if they'd got marianoinette, she'd be dead. There's no question about that.
你不觉得吗？是的，他们会用她的内脏做帽徽。他们会屠杀她。我记得我小时候看过一部关于法国大革命的纪录片，一种戏剧化的纪录片之类的。这个场景是它的核心。你可以说这个场景在某种程度上是，我敢说，保守派想象力的核心。这是一个经典的隐喻，不是吗？
Do you not think? Yes, they would have made cockades out of her entrails. They would have butchered her. And I remember when I was a boy seeing a documentary about the French Revolution, a sort of dramatised documentary or something like that. And this scene was at the centre of it. And you could argue this scene is, in a way, the centre of, dare I say, the conservative imagination. It's a classic trope, isn't it?
失控的暴民和泪流满面、逃命的女人，他们要屠杀她。我的意思是，那非常伯克（Burkean），我想，那个形象，不是吗？绝对是，这就是为什么他在对革命的抨击中那样定位玛丽·安托瓦内特。但它并没有那样爆发。她最终没有死。她与路易团聚了。同样，我认为这很大程度上要归功于拉法耶特，他被告知了正在发生的事情。是的。他一直在睡觉。他只睡了半小时，多米尼克。他醒了。他没有说：“哦，别管我。我需要补觉。”他冲了出来。哦，真是个英雄。来到庭院，他看到这些皇家保镖的头颅在棍子上晃来晃去，他让每个人都冷静下来。我的意思是，他设法
The out-of-control mob and the woman in tears fleeing for her life and they are going to butcher her. I mean, that's very Burkean, I guess, that image, isn't it? It absolutely is, which is why he situates Marie Antoinette in the way he does in his Jeremiah against the revolution. But it doesn't explode in that way. She doesn't end up dead. She is reunited with Louis. And again, I think a lot of the credit for this can be given to Lafayette, who has been alerted to what's happening. Yeah. Who's been asleep. He's smashed half an hour of sleep, Dominic. He's woken up. He doesn't go, oh, leave me alone. I need to catch up on my sleep. He comes rushing out. Oh, what a hero. Comes into the courtyard and he sees these heads of the royal bodyguards on sticks kind of bobbing around and he calms everybody down. I mean, he manages to
说：“嘿，伙计们，冷静点。”然后他说：“我们是人民的保镖。”然后他进去，对王后表现得非常像托尼·布莱尔。他告诉国王和王后：“看，我们必须平息局势。”路易一直在说关于卫兵践踏帽徽的事情。那从未发生过。拉法耶特说：“是的，没关系。好吧。我们要做的是，你必须走到阳台上，你必须向外面的人群讲话。我已经尽力安抚他们了，但最终最好还是由你亲自来说。”所以路易走到阳台上，他向人群讲话，他说：“是的，我会和你们一起去巴黎。”他再次坚持他的保镖是无辜的，他们没有
say, you know, guys, just, you know, chill. And then he goes, we're the people's bodyguard. And then he goes in and is very Tony Blair and the queen. He tells the king and queen, look, we've got to calm the situation down. And Louis is saying all this stuff about, you know, the guard trampling on the cocaine. It never happened. And Laferte says, yeah, fine. Okay. What we've got to do is you've got to go out on the balcony and you have got to address the people outside. I've done my best to calm them down, but ultimately it's best coming from you. So Louis then goes out onto the balcony and he addresses the crowd and he says, yes, I will come with you to Paris. Again, he insists that his bodyguards are innocent, that they hadn't
践踏帽徽。拉法耶特和他在一起，他在公关方面非常、非常出色。他做的是，他拿了一个三色帽徽，拥抱了一名保镖军官，并将帽徽别在保镖的帽子上。通过这样做，他本质上是将保镖纳入了革命的温暖怀抱中。我认为，我的意思是，你可能会说这非常托尼·布莱尔。我不认为这一定是一种批评，多米尼克。我认为他做得很好。
trampled on the cockade. Lafayette is with him and he's very, very good at the PR. What he does is he takes a tricolour cockade and he embraces an officer of the bodyguard and he pins the cockade to the bodyguard's hat. And by doing that, he's essentially folding the bodyguard into the warm embrace of the revolution. I think that's, I mean, you may say it's very Tony Blair. I don't necessarily see that as a criticism, Dominic. I think he's done very well.
在一个可怕的情况下，本来很容易以国王、王后和拉法耶特本人被菜刀屠杀而告终。他实际上表现得，我的意思是，睡着了，我认为是疯狂的。但实际上，关于帽徽的事情是一场精彩的政治表演。还有更多的事情要发生，不是吗，关于王后？嗯，确实，因为仍然存在王后的问题，暴民会憎恨她。所以拉法耶特说：“看，你也必须走到阳台上。”她很害怕，我的意思是，完全可以理解，她
In a horrific situation, which could easily have ended with the king, the queen, and Lafayette himself being butchered with kitchen knives. He's actually played, I mean, falling asleep, I think, is madness. But actually, the stuff with the cockade is a brilliant bit of political theatre. And there's more to come, isn't there, with the queen? Well, there is, because there is still the question of the queen, who the mob will hate. And so Lafayette says look you've got to go out onto the balcony as well and she's terrified i mean entirely understandably she's
听到了他们关于她的叫喊声，所以拉法耶特说：“不，你必须去。”所以她带着孩子们走到阳台上，但庭院里的人开始为此叫嚣，说她必须独自站在那里，所以她让孩子们回去了。她走到阳台上，面对着半小时前还想撕碎她内脏的人群。同样，拉法耶特加入了她，他在她面前深深鞠躬，亲吻了她的手。有一种沉默，不清楚人群的反应会是什么。然后他们开始高喊：“王后万岁。”同样，拉法耶特驾驭了情绪的浪潮，扭转了
heard what they were shouting about her so but lafayette says no you must and so she goes out onto the balcony with her children but the people out in the courtyard start baying at this and saying she has to stand there alone so she sends the children back in. She steps out onto the balcony facing the crowd who only half an hour before were wanting to rip out her intestines. And again, Lafayette joins her and he bows low before her and he kisses her hand. And there's a kind of silence and it's not clear what the reaction of the crowd is going to be. And then they start shouting, long live the queen. And again, Lafayette has kind of ridden the wave of emotion and turned it,
局势。所以玛丽·安托瓦内特回到了里面，但当然她仍然完全受到创伤。我认为她可能比路易更清楚地看到了他们现在显然面临的恐怖规模。所以她回到里面，对一位侍女说：“他们想强迫我们，国王和我，带着我们保镖的头颅，在长矛顶端在我们面前游行，去巴黎。”而这正是发生的事情。他们乘坐马车从凡尔赛到巴黎花了七个小时。一路上，路易没有说一句话。人们在马车行驶时喊着口号，并对王后
turned the tide. And so Marie Antoinette goes back inside, but of course she's still completely traumatized. And I think she sees perhaps even more clearly than Louis, the scale of the horrors that clearly now face them. So she goes back in and she speaks to a lady in waiting and she says, they want to force us, the king and me, to go to Paris with the heads of our bodyguards carried before us at the end of their pikes. And this is exactly what happens. And it takes them seven hours to travel in their carriage from Versailles to Paris. The whole way, Louis doesn't utter a single word. You have people kind of shouting slogans and just
指指点点。在皇家马车后面，是装满了从凡尔赛仓库里拿走的所有面粉的马车。当他们到达巴黎时，他们被迫再次出现在阳台上，这次是在市政厅。然后最终，到晚上8点，他们能够瘫倒在分配给他们的宫殿——杜伊勒里宫。令人难以置信的是，在那里迎接他们的人是阿克塞尔·冯·费森，那位每个人都认为与玛丽·安托瓦内特有染的潇洒瑞典外交官。我的意思是，他出现在那里简直是疯了。所以王后的一名助手说：
sticulating the queen as the carriage rides along. Behind the royal carriage, there are wagons loaded with all the flour that had been taken from the stores at Versailles. And on their arrival in Paris, they're forced to appear again on a balcony, this time at the Hotel de Ville. And then finally, by 8 p.m., they are able to kind of collapse into the palace that's been allocated to them, the Tuileries. And unbelievably, the person who is there to greet them is Axel von Fersen, the dashing Swedish diplomat who everyone thinks has been having an affair with Marie Antoinette. I mean, it's just madness that he's there. And so an aide to the Queen says,
“看，离开这里。如果人们发现你在这里，你会被撕成碎片。”所以他照做了。他们显然非常、非常沮丧。没有人比王太子更沮丧，他抱怨他的房间非常丑陋。尽管必须说，他不会有更糟糕的结局了，多米尼克。是的，这很有趣，不是吗？
look, get out of here. You're going to be torn to pieces if people find you here. So he does that. They're obviously very, very depressed. And no one is more depressed than the Dauphin, who complains that his room is very ugly. Although it has to be said, he will come to no worse, Dominic. Yeah, it's interesting, isn't it?
因为一些听众可能会说：“嗯，这太偏颇了。你知道，我一点也不为他们感到难过。他们被宠坏了，享有特权，诸如此类。当人们挨饿时，他们住在凡尔赛镀金的辉煌中。他们罪有应得，等等等等。”就我个人而言，我认为在人类层面上，特别是玛丽·安托瓦内特和针对她的厌女症，我认为很难持有那种观点。我同意。我的意思是，这是一个
Because some listeners might well say, well, this is terribly biased. You know, I don't feel sorry for them at all. They're pampered and privileged and all that kind of thing. And they're living in the gilded splendor of Versailles when people are hungry. They had it coming, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Personally, I think on a human level, especially Marianne Toinette and the misogyny directed at her, I think it's quite hard to take that view. I agree. I mean, it's a directed at her. I think it's quite hard to take that view. I agree. I mean, it's a terrible ordeal and I think a terrible story.
可怕的磨难，我认为是一个可怕的故事。但作为反衬，我们在叙述中没有给出的是一个孩子正在饿死的妇女的故事。当然。我完全同意你的看法。所以这就是反衬。所以我认为总是有关于伟大和迷人的故事，因为我们知道细节，总是更加耀眼。我们没有那些被绝望驱使去向凡尔赛进军的人的叙述，而那才是反衬。法国人总是说英国人特别喜欢从伯克开始讲述这个故事，
But to counterpoint that, what we haven't given in this account is the narrative of a woman whose children are starving to death. Of course. No, I totally agree with you. So that is the counterpoint to it. So I think there's always the story of the great and the glamorous, because we know the details, always kind of blaze more brightly. We don't have the account of someone who has been driven by despair to march on Versailles, and that is the counterpoint. French people always say the British in particular love telling the story from Burke onwards,
卡莱尔，狄更斯。他们喜欢通过眼睛，你知道，带着一种恐怖感，对革命的着迷的恐怖感来讲述这个故事。他们特别通过伟大和美好的人的眼睛，尤其是玛丽·安托瓦内特。你在本系列的第一集中提到了克尔斯滕·邓斯特的电影，当那部电影上映时，法国评论家说：“哦，典型的盎格鲁-撒克逊人。他们总是通过玛丽·安托瓦内特的眼睛讲述故事。”嗯，我认为法国大革命是一个伟大且至今仍有争议的主题。他们总是通过玛丽·安托瓦内特的眼睛讲述故事。我的意思是，这至今仍构成了对革命的态度。我们现在可以看到这一点。但当然，在国王和王后从凡尔赛被转移到杜伊勒里宫之后，仍然有两个显而易见的问题没有解决。
Carlyle, Dickens. They love to tell the story through the eyes, you know, with a sense of horror, fascinated horror at the revolution. And they particularly through the eyes of the great and the good and Marie Antoinette more than anybody. You mentioned in the very first episode in the series, the Kirsten Dunst film, when that came out, French critics said, oh, typical Anglo-Saxons. They always tell the story through the eyes of Marie Antoinette. Well, I think the French revolution is a great and still enduringly controversial subject They always tell the story through the eyes of Maritza Nett. I mean, this still structures attitudes to the revolution to this day. And we can see that now. But of course, in the aftermath of the transportation of the king and queen from Versailles to the Tuileries, there are still two obvious problems that have not been solved.
事实上，把国王和王后带到巴黎，在某种程度上，只是让问题变得更加明显。所以首先，君主制如何与革命相协调？在所谓的“十月事件”之后，即我们描述的所有事件，宪法委员会和国民议会下定决心，要消除他们所看到的专制主义回归的任何前景。所以国王失去了所有提议法律的权利。法令规定他的收入将由国民议会的投票决定。
And in fact, the bringing of the king and queen to Paris, in a way, has only made more glaring. So firstly, how is the monarchy to be squared with the revolution? And in the wake of the October days, as they're called, all the events we've been describing, there's a determined effort on behalf of the Constitutional Committee and the National Assembly to remove any prospect of despotism as they see it coming back. So the king loses all his rights to propose laws. It's decreed that his income will be determined by a vote in the National Assembly.
他必须允许，如果判定他的大臣们背叛了革命，他们将被弹劾。所以本质上，支撑他权力的所有支柱都被彻底敲掉了。问题是，路易将如何适应这一点？他将如何应对被这样阉割，成为一个纯粹的宪法符号。所以这是一个悬而未决的问题。但另一个悬而未决的问题是，国民议会能否保持其作为国家代言人的角色？因为它被抢了风头，就像国王和王后被抢了风头一样。嗯，国民议会认为主权在我们手中。现在看来，主权掌握在巴黎街头的这些人群手中。掌握在人民手中。所以这并不奇怪
He has to allow that his ministers will be impeached if it is judged that they're betraying the revolution. So essentially, all the struts upholding his power have been completely knocked away. And the question is, how will Louis adapt to this? How will he cope with being neutered in this way, becoming a mere constitutional cipher. So that's an open question. But the other open question is, will the National Assembly be able to preserve its role as the voice of the nation? Because it has been upstaged just as the King and Queen have been upstaged. Well, the National Assembly thought sovereignty lies with us. It now appears that sovereignty lies with these crowds on the streets of Paris. With the people. So it's unsurprising
在10月中旬，国民议会跟随国王和王后从凡尔赛来到巴黎。他们生活在意识到两个巨大风险的情况下。第一个是他们会分裂成派系，正如已经开始发生的那样，分裂成左派和右派，但也存在来自不属于议会的人干预的持续风险。而且，你知道，伴随着暴力的风险，如果代表们不按照人民的意愿立法，他们将会面临什么，这现在是悬在国民议会每一位代表头上的达摩克利斯之剑。达摩克利斯之剑。
that in mid-October, the National Assembly follows the King and Queen from Versailles to Paris. And they are living with the consciousness of two massive risks. The first is that they will fragment into factions, as has already begun to happen, the fragmenting into left and right, but also the ongoing risk of interventions from people who are not part of the assembly. And, you know, with the concurrent risk of violence, the threat of what will happen to the deputies if they do not legislate in accordance with the wishes of the people is now a Damocles sword hanging over every deputy in the National Assembly. A sword of Damocles.
十月中旬，国民议会跟随国王和王后从凡尔赛迁往巴黎。他们生活在两种巨大风险的意识之中。第一种是他们会分裂成不同的派系，正如已经开始发生的那样，分裂成左派和右派；但同时还存在着来自议会之外的人进行干预的持续风险。而且，你知道，伴随着暴力的风险，如果代表们的立法不符合人民的意愿，他们将会遭遇什么，这种威胁现在就像达摩克利斯之剑一样悬在国民议会每一位代表的头上。一把达摩克利斯之剑。
We've had the storm clouds of revolution and now we have the sword of Damocles. We've had the storm clouds of revolution, and now we have the sword of Damocles. Brilliant. And this is a development that is obviously very, very pregnant with implications for the future. So back in Versailles, some of the more radical deputies had joined a club that had originally been set up by the deputies from Brittany. And now they've moved to Paris. They are looking for a new place to meet. So they rent a meeting room that is conveniently located near the new hall where the National Assembly are meeting. And initially membership of this club is limited to deputies. But as the months go by, it starts to be opened up to ordinary citizens. I mean, citizens who, you know, they have to pay a
我们经历了革命的乌云，现在又面临达摩克利斯之剑。我们经历了革命的乌云，现在又面临达摩克利斯之剑。太精彩了。这一事态的发展显然对未来有着非常深远的影响。回到凡尔赛，一些更激进的代表加入了一个最初由布列塔尼代表建立的俱乐部。现在他们搬到了巴黎。他们正在寻找一个新的聚会地点。于是他们租了一个会议室，位置就在国民议会开会的新大厅附近。起初，这个俱乐部的成员仅限于代表。但随着时间的推移，它开始向普通公民开放。我是说，公民们，你知道，他们必须支付一笔
membership fee, but otherwise they can all kind of join it. And this club, they call themselves Les Amis de la Constitution, the Friends of the Constitution. But increasingly, Dominic, they come to be known by another name. And it's a name that derives from the fact that they have rented their meeting room from the order of the Dominicans. And in Paris, the Dominicans have a very distinctive nickname. And it derives from the fact that the very first Dominican monastery in Paris, way back in the middle ages, had been on the Rue Saint-Jacques. And so they come to be called Jacobins. And this is the nickname that comes to be given to the most radical of the clubs
会员费，但除此之外，他们基本上都可以加入。这个俱乐部自称为“宪法之友”。但多米尼克，他们越来越以另一个名字为人所知。这个名字源于他们从多米尼克修会租用会议室的事实。在巴黎，多米尼克修会有一个非常独特的绰号。它源于巴黎的第一座多米尼克修道院，早在中世纪就位于圣雅克街。因此，他们被称为雅各宾派。这就是后来赋予最激进俱乐部的绰号
in paris and the existence of the jacobin as events will prove spells nothing good for the royal family well you know what ben kenobi said about the jacobin club tom you will never find a more wretched hive of scum and villainy. And on that bombshell, thank you so much for this terrifying story or inspirational story. We will be back tomorrow with the final episode for now of the French Revolution series, when we will be talking about how the royal family tried to make a break for it in disguise. Probably the most extraordinary scene in French history if not european history the king and queen of europe's largest country in disguise fleeing through france pursued by agents of the revolution desperate to get to the frontier before they can be stopped and accompanied by the
在巴黎，正如事件所证明的那样，雅各宾派的存在对王室来说绝非好事。好吧，汤姆，你知道本·肯诺比是怎么评价雅各宾俱乐部的吗？你永远找不到比这更卑劣的恶棍和坏蛋窝了。带着这个重磅炸弹，非常感谢你讲述这个可怕或鼓舞人心的故事。我们明天将回来播出法国大革命系列的最后一集（目前为止），届时我们将讨论王室成员如何试图乔装逃跑。这可能是法国历史上，如果不是欧洲历史上，最非凡的场景：欧洲最大国家的国王和王后乔装打扮，穿过法国逃亡，被革命特工追捕，拼命想在被拦截前到达边境，并由
hairdresser and yeah well the hairdresser an important part of their ménage so the flight to varennes will be tomorrow's final episode of this part of the series the rest of the series we will be pursuing I think in the autumn is that right Tom? that's right so you've got that to look forward to
理发师陪同，是的，理发师是他们随行人员的重要组成部分。所以，瓦雷纳出逃将是本系列这一部分的最后一集。至于系列的其余部分，我想我们会在秋季继续，对吧，汤姆？没错，所以你们可以期待一下
but Tom merci beaucoup et au revoir au revoir I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews
那么，汤姆，非常感谢，再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐余波》。这是你们每周的娱乐新闻和评论
splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening
以及一点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听
bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
奖励剧集和提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。